okay welcome everybody this is HTTP in
asp.net core in Linux and docker Linux
containers we're gonna dig into
certificates and how we use certificates
inside of docker to produce a similar
debugging results which is really cool
so here's the part where I tell you I'm
definitely gonna post my slides on my
blog tonight you're gonna check tomorrow
next week next month in about three
months you're gonna get tired of waiting
you're gonna email me I'm gonna reply in
six months and say no I'm definitely
going to post them on my blog tonight
and I'll never post the middle which is
why if you go to rob rich org right now
you can click on presentations you can
scroll down to this talk right here and
you can look at the slides or the code
right now they are online right now at
Rob rich org achievement unlocked so
while you're here click out here on
about me and you'll learn a little bit
about me I'm a Microsoft MVP a friend of
Redgate some of the other things that
I've done Daisy give camp is
particularly exciting a Z give camp
brings volunteer developers together
with charities who otherwise couldn't
afford software services we start
building software for them Friday after
work Sunday afternoon we deliver those
completed projects back to the charities
it is really really fun sleep is
optional caffeine provided if you're in
Arizona in Phoenix come look us up
because that is really really cool one
of the things I'm particularly proud of
is that I replied to a dotnet Rox
episode they read my reply on the air
they sent me a mug and if you'd like a
written no just kidding so that's a
little bit about me but we're here to
learn about HTTP we talked about this
guy HTTP so here's kind of where we're
gonna go why do we have certificates
what is what's in a certificate how does
asp.net do this in the box and what can
we do about that how do we do that in
docker
and how do we fix it and then net result
do you give me five stars on Yelp whoa
yeah so that's gonna be fun so why
certificates well this is Troy hunt he's
the guy on the left he came to the
United States government and tried to
explain to them how cybersecurity works
I love it
his Aussie socks those are just really
cool so you know ultimately government
people are what they are so they
actually had to go interview Facebook
and all these other people to try and
figure out if their pics on their phone
got sent to their wives I'm not sure why
that was a relevant question but yeah so
why certificates if your answer is
because Troy told me so that is a
perfectly legitimate answer and I
completely applaud that yes use
certificates because Troy told me so so
ultimately you know digging it a little
bit deeper than because Troy hunt told
me to why would I use certificates
well certificates usually serve two main
purposes the first one I will encrypt
the traffic over the wire so that nobody
can snoop on it and see what I'm doing
and the second is so that I can verify
that the server is who I expect it to be
now that's the client validating that
the server is who we expect it to be we
could use certificates the other way we
could have client certificates so that
the server could validate that the
client is who they say there but client
certificates are hard so we generally
don't we generally use session cookies
instead so as I first connect to the
service I'll authenticate to them
they'll create a session cookie they'll
put that on my machine and that's how
the server validates the client because
I pass them back the session cookie next
time I make a request how does the
client validate it's the server that I'm
talking to
well that's certificates and so those
are the two things we encrypt the
message and we validate the message so
why is this important well here's fire
sheep fire sheep was a plugin for
Firefox and fire sheep would
go to a particular website and go steal
that session cookie so I have here on
the left a list of session cookies that
I found in that coffee shop and now I
just click on whatever persona I want to
be and it uses that session cookie to
connect to the website so I just pick
who I want to be because I'm passing in
the session cookie then the server says
yeah here's your Facebook page why did
that happen because Facebook was using
HTTP instead of HTTP so how do we block
this attack well use HTTP now my session
cookie is no longer sent through the air
and ultimately we can't get to where we
need to go our Packers can't get my data
in the middle another great example is a
pineapple this device this little Wi-Fi
device will just listen to network
traffic as I broadcast out saying hey is
my Wi-Fi network available you know how
you get home and your phone
automatically notices that you've gotten
home and connects to your Wi-Fi it's
broadcasting looking for that Wi-Fi
signal so the pineapple just says yeah
I'm that so of course I'm going to
connect I'm going to pass in my Wi-Fi
credentials then I'm going to send all
my web traffic through it the pineapple
then very carefully proxies that traffic
off to the real server and I'm none the
wiser that they're now able to spy on my
traffic well why are they able to spy on
my traffic because I'm connecting to web
sites with HTTP instead of HTTPS so we
thwart this attack by using certificates
now we can't see that traffic in transit
so let's take this example we create
these we create these tunnels these HTTP
tunnels so that we encrypt all of our
traffic from here to there
now that encryption process is really
elegant and it makes sure that my
traffic can't be intercepted in the
middle so let's imagine that we have
Alice here and Alice is connecting to
Bob
calm and Bob calm is using a TLS
certificate so you know HTTP works
successfully and all is good all of the
traffic is encrypted and ultimately we
we can't see what's going on in their
communication now let's imagine that we
have someone let's call him Jerry so
Jerry comes in here in the middle and
Jerry's gonna try and spy on the traffic
well
Jerry can't see anything right because
it's it's HTTP well Jerry's gonna do
something really interesting
Jerry is going to create an HTTPS
certificate as well so Alice connects to
Jerry Jerry proxies the traffic back to
Bob calm Bob calm hands of certificate
Jerry sends a new certificate back to
Alice and Alice has an encrypted
connection to something and Alice
believes all as well if we're only using
HTTPS for encryption then this is
completely possible I put a certificate
in both places and I can attack any site
that I need to so ultimately it's not
just about encryption it is also about
validating that that server is who I say
that server is so in this case I don't
want to talk to Jerry I want to talk to
the website so how do we validate the
authenticity of a website ultimately we
look for this we've taught our users
that they need to find that lock in the
top left corner of their address bar and
each browser presents it in a little bit
different way but ultimately you know
I'm looking for that lock or that green
bar or that thing that says that that
site is who I expect them to be and so
ultimately I get to a page like this and
now we need to teach users that you
don't just click advanced and click
proceed that's a certificate fail I love
bad com bad certificate com because it's
able to highlight these kind of errors
in really interesting ways so we're
still
trying to teach them not to do this you
know proceed anyway thing well your
certificates expired
well temporarily can you just click
proceed but never ever do that again
except for every time I tell you to do
that you know that that's what we're
kind of training our users to do is you
know you look for the lock except for
when you don't so a moment about DV and
DV certificates domain validated versus
extended validated certificates domain
validated certificates tell me that that
server is responsible for that domain
and that's all it says is that you know
if I were to reach out to that domain
I'm reaching out to the correct server
extended validated certificates take it
a step further and say that search it
that server is part of this organization
so to get an extended validation
certificate they'll call the phone
number on their website they'll talk to
executives and they'll validate that
that organization is who they say
they're and ultimately then we either
get a kind of nice green block or we get
the big green bar and that's interesting
but you know ultimately our users are
like well is it this or is it not this
do I have to click proceed anyway so you
know the industry kind of went yeah
domain validated extended validated I
don't care I just don't want this so
browser certificates if I come up here I
see that this site is trusted it has a
lock here in the corner and I can click
on that and it'll pop up this box and
it'll tell me about the certificate so
here in this certificate dialog and each
operating system and browser is ever so
slightly different but it'll tell me
that here the certificate was valid from
January 7th 2019 to July 17th 2019 it
will tell me a little bit more about
that certificate here's the version the
signature algorithm sha-256 is a great
one
I'm valid from invalid to which I'm not
sure why Microsoft calls it that
everyone else calls it not before and
not after but you know there's the dates
here's the domains and other details
that it works for so you know this
domain is sni one four seven five one
seven CloudFlare SSL com so yeah proxy
my site through Claude Fleur some public
key details
here's subject alternate names and
subject alternate names is really
interesting because this is the other
domains that are also supported on the
same certificate so if this certificate
came back from one of these other
domains it would still be valid so
there's a few here you know CloudFlare
is wonderful at proxying lots of things
but there's my site Rob rich org and now
this certificate is trusted well why is
it trusted well one of the other things
that we have in here is this thumbprint
and that's kind of the serial number for
this certificate or the unique
identifier of this certificate yeah
there's a certificate proper serial
number property but we use thumbprint to
kind of reference that there's that
thumbprint that serial number if I have
that serial number then I know that I
have that certificate so we have then a
trust chain why is this one green well
this certificate was signed by this
certificate and I can click on this one
and click view certificate and pull up
similar details for that certificate and
that one was signed by this certificate
and that one was signed by this
certificate and ultimately then I get to
this certificate and now I'll come in to
[Music]
manage user certificates or manage
computer certificates those assigned to
my local machine or those assigned to me
personally so I've already pulled those
up here's the user certificates and the
computer certificates I've popped open
the trusted root certificate store
and here in the trusted root certificate
store I can kind of cruise through the
certificates that have been
pre-installed on my machine and Windows
Update gets these into place so as
Windows Update goes it will give me new
root certificates and so ultimately that
certificate here at the top of the chain
was pre-installed on my machine in here
I trust this certificate this
certificate signed this certificate
which signed this certificate and
ultimately signed this certificate and
therefore I will go green for this
certificate so we looked at browser
certificates and we looked at
certificate stores that's really
interesting we saw some of the
properties associated with that as you
pull up these slides later on Rob rich
org that'll be really helpful to you
know see what we demoed in the previous
slide we look through the subject name
the domain and the subject alternate
names the other domains and in
particular the thumbprint and the trust
chain we walked that trust chain to see
that I pre trusted this certificate that
was there root of the certificate that
ultimately served me and that's why the
certificate is green so what can go
wrong here well probably the most likely
thing is that certificate expired when I
get to that not after date and I'm past
that well yeah I'm gonna get that gray
screen where I have to hit proceed
because that certificate expired it'd be
nice to kind of keep track of that and
you know know when I need to renew that
do I have a calendar entry on my
calendar to make me go renew that
certificate well what else can go wrong
well we could use an insert cure
algorithm a year or two or three ago we
all upgraded from sha-1 to sha-256
because sha-1 was no longer considered a
secure cryptographic algorithm the big
thing that goes wrong and the thing
we'll focus on here is the trust chain
and we saw where we act
gently connected to Gerry instead of
connecting to the website that we wanted
to and that ultimately didn't yield us a
great experience I love bad SSL right
here this is a link that will pop open
this site bad SSL is a site that allows
us to construct various bad certificate
conditions so for example if I want to
hit a expired certificate and see what
happens here's that thing it says error
cert date invalid and I could click
proceed and dig into how that works but
I just got a bad certificate associated
with this experience just by clicking in
through bad SSL com
so as you're testing your site to make
sure that it can do interesting things
that can be a great resource for finding
broken trust chains finding expired or
invalid certificates and doing all kinds
of other things okay so we looked at
certificate stores on Windows we have
certain manager both the user side and
the computer side that allows us to do
things
Firefox takes it a little bit
differently Firefox doesn't use that
store rather they have their own if I
come in here to options and I view
certificates here are the certificates
that they've pre-installed rather than
using the Windows trust store why do
they have their own yeah so that's
interesting so on Windows we have this
central store on Linux I love this
comment on the asp.net github post they
filed an issue and the answer was
trusting the certificate is only
available on Windows and Mac OS because
there is no standard way of trusting the
certificate on Linux well kind of if
you're on this one you can trust it this
way and if you're on this one you can
trust it this way here are all the
places where they keep that master list
of certificates that they trust but you
know I don't want to care about
this list so of course there's a bunch
of programs that ignore that list
completely Firefox Chrome on Linux
doesn't use that list they have their
own Apache Java Kestrel the built-in
asp.net web server doesn't use the trust
or they use a certificate placed
somewhere else so on Linux it's kind of
this free-for-all as we get into docker
we're gonna kind of fall into that where
there isn't a standard trust store that
we need to play into so in production
how do I do production certificates
I want that trust chain I want to be a
certificate that I bought from a valid
place or that I grabbed from a trusted
spot so that then all of my users have
pre-installed that trust chain and I'll
get a green certificate so step one use
let's encrypt let's encrypt is really
elegant for this what if I do if I don't
want to use let's encrypt well you start
off by buying a certificate and of
course then you go looking for the
download button and they say there isn't
a download button so I go create a key I
use that to create a CSR I upload the
CSR to their site they use that to sign
the certificate in interesting ways I
download that certificate I go try and
install it into my web server and oh
crap I downloaded the wrong certificate
so now I go back to the site do I need
to re-upload the CSR do I need to create
a new CSR do I eventually get the right
certificate I installed it on my web
server and ultimately it doesn't work
and so then step nine I use let's
encrypt so let's encrypt let's encrypt
is really really cool because they offer
this free certificate service you put a
daemon on your website and you connect
to their cert their certificate store
and you make a request they make a
request back to validate that you own
that domain ultimately they issue the
certificate and that daemon ends up
installing that certificate on your web
server no fuss happens automatically so
they have really short-lived
certificates that are able to do that
process whenever they need to to keep
your certificate up-to-date it is really
really cool
so in production by a certificate or use
let's encrypt outside of production well
now what here on the let's encrypt docks
they talk about what to do in production
are outside of production so one of the
cool things that they do is validate
that you own the domain nobody can own
localhost so they can't issue a
certificate for localhost they have to
make that inbound requests into your
system so you don't have a public if you
don't have a publicly accessible IP they
can't issue a certificate for that
domain so in development and testing
yeah we can't use let's encrypt that's a
bummer and ultimately what they invite
us to do is to use open SSL to go create
a self-signed certificate yeah ok
so in development and testing what can
we do well what's really cool because
we're in this asp.net ecosystem we have
this really cool development experience
kind of baked in let's look at that I
have Visual Studio 2017 here
I just went file new project I tweaked
it a smidge but in this case it's the
standard stuff I'll set this as my
startup project and because we want to
use kestrel not is Express I'm going to
come in here to the drop-down and I'm
going to choose the my project as
opposed to is Express I don't want the
is Express details in this because we
won't have i Express when we get to
docker so I'm going to fire up this
solution I'll actually set multiple
startup projects here and let's fire up
this site there's kestrel firing up
it's gonna launch a browser here's my
browser and I have a trusted certificate
I have a green lock well why is this
lock green if I click here on view
certificate here's my certificate it's
issued to localhost I'm browsing to
localhost that's great
it's not expired I can come looking here
at the details and see that it is the
asp.net development certificate I can
look at this thumbprint ultimately that
certificate is here in my certificate
store not that one this one here's the
localhost certificate and that one has
that same thumbprint FD zero eight one
five here's the certificate that I trust
here's the certificate that I got from
the website FD zero eight one five it is
a self signed certificate but I trust
that certificate therefore I get HTTPS
in the box from visual studio well
that's really cool I also went to http
localhost five thousand it did the
automatic redirect that's really cool
here in Visual Studio
let's go looking for you know where's
the plumbing that did that well here in
program CS we don't see anything
different from an HTTP to an HTTP
project so it's not here here in
start-up CS we'll see a little bit of a
distraction there's things in here about
use HTTP use HSTs certificate pinning
that's really elegant because then they
won't have to keep downloading the
certificate and I've told them to only
use HTTPS going forward for this site we
only do that in production because we
don't want to pin our development
machine to a fake certificate that would
be bad
undoing that as a really interesting
Google search by the way we see this use
HTTP redirection that's interesting but
those are the only clues here that we
have HTTPS going on well where is the
HTTP magic is it in app settings no app
settings is pretty blend here inside
launch settings inside the property
folder we see that is Express content we
can just delete that we don't need that
for this demo we want to use kestrel so
going forward we have just that one
thing in the list and we can see a
little bit of a clue we now have two
URLs here the application URL is HTTP
localhost 5001 and HTTP localhost 5,000
i've told it to launch on to urls
instead of just one and one of them is
HTTP but I haven't specified a
certificate I haven't done any of the
rest of that well that's really cool
obligatory kittens so out of the box we
have this great HTTP development story
from visual studio
I have certificates that I've pre
trusted I can hit that certificate and I
can do really elegant things it's going
to do automatic HTTP redirection in
production all have certificate pinning
that's great so ultimately how does this
happen in program CS we had web host
create default web builder asp.net is
open source so let's go looking at
create default web builder well that's
going to go create the builder and it
goes and does a bunch of stuff about is
it development go grab the user secrets
that's really cool grab environment
variables configure logging ooh
configure web defaults that's pretty
cool
configure web defaults
so configure web defaults and this is a
link that will pop us open to this page
configure web default says hey builder
use kestrel okay so it's gonna go grab
that kestrel section from the web config
we didn't have a Kestrel section in our
web config so digging a little bit
deeper you know there's a whole lot more
calls that happen and then ultimately we
go try to find that developer
certificate file get try get certificate
path so it's gonna look inside app data
it's gonna look inside the home
environment variable if either of those
are set it's gonna go look for a
specific path inside there and it's
ultimately going to look for app name
dot pfx well I don't have an app named
dot pfx but let's keep digging in there
ultimately it's going to look for CN
equals localhost so that's here is it a
development certificate well it is if
the CN is localhost if the domain is
specifically for localhost and only
local host is that the development
certificate digging it a bit further
it's like well how does it know how to
use this as opposed to whatever's passed
to it well if it has some addresses then
it'll use the addresses if it doesn't
have the addresses then it will use this
default address strategy which means go
figure it out if I didn't have those
launch options JSON then it would dig in
here and ultimately there's a constant
way way deep in that call stack which
says localhost 5,000 that's how it knows
how to launch on localhost 5,000 go grab
that development certificate and
ultimately launch kestrel to do
interesting things and then what's
really cool is it also says now
listening on and it'll spit out those
those ports well how does it get these
ports it's looping through addresses
that it gets here from the server
features the server address features and
then it's just looping on the splitting
on semicolon
so I passed it that list of URLs to
launch it split that on semicolon and
did some interesting things and then
ultimately console.log those to say I'm
now launching on these two ports I love
that asp.net is open source now so
that's kind of how we get from this
program that says nothing about a
certificate to automatically getting
this certificate out of the box that's
really cool and all that was built in as
I installed Visual Studio it fired it up
if I'm not using Visual Studio as I
install the.net SDK on Linux
I'll get my certificate dumped in this
directory dotnet slash core FX / you
know blah blah blah blah blah startup
pfx and it's a PF X file it's not a PEM
server file even though it's on Linux
it's a PF X file bummer it's not in that
Linux trust store they just kind of
stuck it in this net directory okay
that's interesting so how do I make this
certificate well I can from the command
line I can say dotnet dev certs HTTP - -
trust and it'll take that certificate
and I'll put it in the trust store for
my OS so I can find this program here
inside see Program Files net SDK 2.2
whatever version I'm on net tools net
dev and so here in that spot here is
that dotnet dev certs DLL but yeah
asp.net is open source so let's go look
at the source for that here's program CS
and programs CS we'll go grab net dev
certs HTTP and then go grab the command
lines as I say trust it'll then call
into this method create asp net
development certificate and ultimately
what's
wonderful and annoying is this trust
certificate method down at the bottom if
the OS platform is Windows then trust it
this way if the OS platform is Mac
trusted this way we're on Linux sorry
we're not gonna trust on Linux they just
punted they didn't try and figure out
you know this distro does it this way
and that distro does it that way they
just say nope
we're not gonna trust that or just get
on Linux so if you say - - trust on
Linux it will not do that
and thus it buries it in its directory
instead
okay so let's dig into how we do this in
docker well in this application we did
some interesting things that I just kind
of glossed over I've launched both
projects again here's that now listening
on HTTP 5001 and now listening on HTTP
5,000 here on the home page I'm gonna go
grab the list of addresses that I'm
bound to which is pretty cool I just
kind of reached into those environment
variables and I did that let's look at
those environment variables here in the
home controller I just reach out into
this gently get endpoint addresses
service or method that looks pretty
familiar I go get the I server address
features I go loop through those split
by semicolon and I go split a spit out
those URLs well I also did something
else kind of interesting here I want to
get at the certificate I want to get out
that thumbprint I want to get out the
trust chain I want to see is that
certificate is the development
certificate loaded in this case it is
and what are those details about that
certificate so of course I head off to
github and I go look at this comment
where David Fowler very specifically
says no don't do it this way so here
inside Kestrel inside the options is
this list of things so yeah of course
David Fowler said definitely don't do
what we're about to do so we're gonna go
grab that server up the listen options
we're gonna reflect into that listen
options property because it's private
let's grab those listen options and
we'll reflect out on those lists and
options the HTTP details including the
certificate or the HTTP details the
address and port so that we can show
them nicely on the screen and while
we're there let's reflect a couple more
interesting certificate details so this
page is trusted this page is trusted
because the certificate here this FD
zero eight one five certificate is in
our trust chain it's a trusted
certificate that's why that works
here's that FD zero eight one five
certificate so the other interesting
thing that we're gonna do here in this
is call an API so here in our home
controller we'll go create a URL and I
you know swap this out with bad SSL comm
to kind of see that experience but then
we'll call this service now this service
is going to do something interesting go
create that HTTP client handler get the
string ace get a sync that URL grab the
status code grab the response
deserialize it into
JSON and ultimately returned that that
URL that values controller is back here
that's doing something really similar
that is just I don't know going and
hacking the end points and grabbing the
certificates so ultimately it'll be able
to return the certificates that the
server is hosting through that URL it's
not resort returning the certificate
itself but rather just unique list of
thumb prints so the other interesting
thing that we're doing here is we're
gonna go grab that certificate in the
middle of doing that TLS handshake so
step one when we google for anything and
land on Stack Overflow about you know
what's wrong with my HTTPS certificate
is that thing about how to turn off
certificate validation remember Bob
accidentally connecting to Jerry well
yeah if I go to do this server
certificate custom validation callback
and I return true here then it will
always accept it whether that
certificate is invalid or not in this
case we're very specifically not doing
that we're gonna look at does the error
match none if it's not failing then it
is valid and we'll continue on and we'll
just kind of grab the other details in
here so how do we do this in docker well
while we're here here's that site but
inside of a docker file so I've hacked
this docker file a smidge to be able to
get at all of the details that we need
if I just said add docker support it
would have had a little bit different
experience but I really wanted this asp
net core URLs in here so I'm
specifically building in debug I'm
specifically starting in development
mode so I don't trigger that HSTs
certificate and then ultimately I'm
launching there so let's kick this off
in in docker docker run all the things
I've built that container previously we
failed
the development certificate is installed
as the SDK is installed here inside vs
code we're not using the SDK we're using
the runtime image this runtime image
doesn't have a development certificate
in it therefore there's no certificate
for kestrel defined therefore starting
this the file doesn't work so why does
this work when I just say docker compose
up or push play inside Visual Studio
when I add docker support because we
don't specify this URL here and so it
will happily launch an HTTP only mode
have you ever deployed your site and you
accidentally left that one HTTP
reference and of course the browser is
going to block it because the rest of
the site is SSL is TLS and this one is
not when we develop in HTTP we kind of
lie to ourselves let's really push
forward and see if we can develop in
HTTP so let's leave that one there and
let's take another stab at this so I
know I need a certificate so I'm doing
the same thing up at the top I'm just
running dotnet dev search HTTP just to
make sure that that certificate is there
it'll output whether it was there or
whether it created it that's kind of
nice and then here's the magic right
here I'm gonna go grab the root net core
FX cryptography and it goes on for a
while that directory and I'm going to
copy it to the new containers root net
FX core FX core quarry cryptography
directory now I have that root
certificate now I have I have that
development certificate so now when I
launch I'll be able to do really
interesting things the rest of this is
identical so let's come in here to
this directory docker compose up we're
launching our server on localhost 5,000
and HTTP 5,000 1 our API is on four
thousand and four thousand one that's
interesting let's go to localhost 5000
and we did get that redirection but we
got a certificate fail why did we get
that certificate fail let's dig in here
to view that certificate
well that development certificate
thumbprint is edie III D 9 e 9 fe now
our development certificate is different
this is for localhost and it's valid but
I don't pre trust this thumbprint I pre
trust my development certificate
thumbprint this is Jerry jumping in the
middle well let's not use that
development certificate let's instead
let me clear that data just to make sure
that that is gone docker composed down
let's look instead at this so I start
out by getting my local development
certificate and I'm going to use that
same dotnet dev certs program to export
my certificate to localhost pfx and i
need to set a password well why do I
need to set a password asp.net is open
source so let's go look at the source to
asp.net here
when I go grab that URL here's where it
goes and looks for it and it passes in
password dot has value and on the other
side to password dot has value is where
it takes in the include private key so
if I pass in a password it will export
the private key and if I don't pass in a
password it will not export the private
key which means the server can't sign
requests why do I need a password
because they were lazy or were they
security conscious you know either way
fine I need to set a password so I get
that localhost pfx and I'm just gonna
set it inside this directory here's our
directory and I have I just put it right
here for convenience my localhost pfx
I'm not going to check this in because
it's the certificate that I trust but I
now have this certificate so inside of
our docker file let's go
copy that certificate into place in our
running container now it has a
certificate well kind of it has a
certificate but the certificate has a
password and the development certificate
doesn't so I need to do some open SSL
magic to convert it to a PEM and a key
convert it back into a pfx very
specifically set a blank password here
and now I have localhost no past pfx it
is my local trusted certificate with the
private key inside of it but without a
password that I'm just going to copy
into that magic directory where
kestrels gonna look for it that is great
for the sake of time let's skip that
skip running that demo and dig straight
into this next one so I've got that
certificate in place but as I call in to
the API I noticed that that certificate
isn't trusted so I'm still not it's
trusted by my local machine but it's not
trusted by the web server so I when I
call the API the API still fails so
let's do a little bit more magic I'm
going to convert it in to PIM and a key
and then I'm going to convert it back
into a pfx with no password again I'm
going to copy that
local host knoweth no pass dot pfx into
the proper spot but because linux
generally uses PIM and key I'm going to
copy that PIM and key into the right
spot and then ultimately run the trust
the certificate piece appropriate to my
Linux distribution and in this case
we're using Alpine and so alpine uses
certificates this way so I'm going to do
this all in one step so it'll be one
layer I will apk update add the CA
certificates remove that apk cache
update the CA certificate so that trusts
the certificate in the certificate store
I'll just go list the directory to
validate that that worked correctly and
then I'll echo that it did ultimately
then firing up the thing so let's go in
there to step five and let's go run that
one docker compose up it starts
that starts with the development
certificate that's already trusted on my
machine and so I'm gonna go to localhost
5000 and now I'll go into the hack and
the hack just say that I've got that FD
zero eight one five certificate that's
the certificate loaded I'm going to go
make an API call and the API call is
going to fail
well that development certificate is
very specifically bound to the domain
localhost and this is making a call out
to HTTP API colon 4001 not localhost so
that's why that trust chain failed it's
still the development certificate I've
installed it in both places but I'm
using a different URL well now why did
it fail here because the docker host
that I'm using is not actually on
localhost it's on mini cube so I got a
name fail here - so that's certificate
we can go look at that certificate it's
issued to local host I have the right
thumbprint but the domain didn't match
and therefore I get this remote name
mismatch okay let's clean that one out
docker composed down okay so for step
six I'd like to do some open SSL magic
I'd like to you know go grab that
certificate and transform it into all
the things I'm going to create a
self-signed certificate but it's going
to include mini cube and it's going to
include API and you know maybe I can do
this really cool thing where I have a
docker container that actually generates
the root certificate and I'll map a
volume so that then maybe it'll just
show up magically on my drive and that
you ever get most of the way through an
engineering problem and realized that
that was a really really dumb idea and
that was just overly complicated yeah
all of those open SSL commands are just
scary so you know open SSL is wonderful
and I love it but I reach for this all
the time I can never remember all those
parameters the most common open SSL
commands as I type open SSL commands it
is the first result on Google I'm not
sure if it's because I just kept
clicking it but it's wonderful here's
how to generate a CSR here's how to
convert a thing to this thing here's how
to check to see if it worked
here's how to convert it into two
different formats all of that stuff in
the previous docker files stick it in
place it is really cool so open SSL is
interesting but that open SSL volume
mapping solution was just too hard so
let's do something different well
there's this really cool program called
make cert Mik cert an open source
program created by one of the engineers
at Google who wanted to do exactly this
and so I download Mik cert using
whatever means that I need to I can grab
it through homebrew or I can go grab it
in Linux from Linux brew after I've
installed NSS tools or whatever I need
to I can grab a Windows binary from
chocolatey or I can just flip over here
to the releases tab and go just download
one so I'll just go download that Exe
and then it is just cake I start off by
saying mixer install and that will
create my root certificate key and also
the root certificate and I'll use that
to sign all of the other certificates
now I have a trust chain that kind of
more represents what I'll see in
production then I can run a second
command mixed cert and just pass it a
list of domains and IP addresses all of
those open SSL commands just disappear
so all of that complexity is gone and I
now have a certificate that matches
exactly what I want it to be
okay so I've downloaded make cert right
here I've run it - - install or -
install rather and it spit out my root
CA and root CA - PEM or def key into
this user app local data folder now for
convenience I'm gonna copy it into my
web directory just so I don't have to go
reach for it in that local app data
folder I don't have the local app data
environment variable set inside of
docker as I'm doing things so yeah that
was annoying to copy through but let's
pop here into this docker file so it
turns out that getting mixer on Linux on
Alpine is a little bit weird so it's
open source I'm just gonna go download
it from github so I have this golang
alpine container I'm going to call this
container cert
I'll go grab NSS tools I need that to be
able to get mixer to run I'll go grab
open SSL just cuz you know I'm here go
build that mixer from source and I now
have mixer on
/bin so now that I have mixed cert let
me go into that root directory and I
will copy my local machines key and PEM
into place and those become the trusted
root certificates for this app and then
I'm gonna say mixer install and mix cert
key file I'm gonna output this as HTTP -
web key HTTP web PEM so there's my key
and my certificate I'm gonna then just
list out all of the things that I need
it to be so I'm gonna say mini cube I'll
also grab the IP address of mini cube
I'll grab localhost I'll grab 127.0.0.1
I'll grab web because that's how docker
compose is gonna launch my app and
ultimately then it'll spit out this key
and PEM a little open SSL magic that I
went crap copied from the open SSL
commands thing and set it in place so
that I can get a PF X file well why
can't I just make a PF X file here I
love this part generating a p12 PKS file
also known as a PF X file containing
certificate and key for legacy
applications score brand-new platform
built on legacy content oops okay so I'm
gonna output it as PEM and key and then
ultimately convert it into pfx I'm doing
my build in the normal way it's still a
debug build because this is not for
production this is for development it's
also gonna copy in that route CA - keep
em my private key for my certificate
authority I don't want that to leak
it's my local one but still that's not
great practice but we're not gonna use
this container for anything interesting
we're gonna throw this away in a minute
our goal goal is to do the build here so
it'll just dump out this debug build
into the dist folder and I'll copy that
from the dist folder here into my app
folder like I did before setting the
environment variables but I'm gonna do
some other things too
I'm gonna go reach into the cert
container and I'm going to grab from
that cert container that mixed search
bin and I'm also going to grab the root
CA dot PEM the public key not the
private key and I'm gonna go grab that
localhost - web pfx and set it in my app
directory I could set it anywhere
because that's the one that will
actually run with my website but putting
it with the rest of my code seemed to
make sense in this case I'm going to set
some environment variables which is not
that unlike the config I would want to
set in the app settings dot JSON but
because I don't want to change my
application at all for production use
I'll just set it as environment
variables here I'm gonna go grab NSS
tools to make mixer twerk mixer install
which will then trust this root
certificate that I copied into place I
don't have the key but I'm not issuing
certificates here so that's okay then
I'm gonna delete NSS tools I don't need
that in my production thing and I'm
doing this all as one layer so it's not
like you know I'm adding it and then
removing it in different layers and then
I'm going to remove that make search bin
as well so I've kind of done all the
things I've trusted my certificate and
put it in the spot where it's trusted
and now I also have my localhost my HTTP
- web pfx in my app folder so that as I
start up now I have this trusted chain
with the correct name so I have a
similar docker file in the API project
that does exactly the same thing with
the exception of it's going to have a
different name here it's going to have
the API name instead of the web name but
otherwise those are exactly the same
compose up my application is running
HTTP mini cube 5000 I didn't clear the
thing let me I did not change my
directory let's do that again
I didn't docker compose down thank you
so check out the wrong demo look it's
still broken CD 7 ok docker compose up
and I've built this docker file
previously as well okay so my
certificate my website is running HTTP
colon slash slash mini cube 5000 I
automatically get redirected to HTTPS
let's go look at that certificate it's
issued to I have no idea what that is
and that's fine because here in the
subject alternate names is all of those
things that I specified mini cube local
host web now it's interesting this
thumbprint isn't the thumbprint of the
certificate that I trusted you know
here's that certificate that I trusted
here's my mixer
certificate and it's thumbprint is BA 3
9 D and this web certificate is e 2 e 8
F so I should get a fail here right well
yeah I'm not trusting this certificate
rather this certificate was signed by
that certificate and that certificate is
BA 390 that's the one that I've pre
trusted and so I get a green lock well
let's go look at this again let's go hit
that we see our 5,000 won and 5,000
let's go try and get the details of that
certificate no it's not a dev cert but
here's that certificate e 2 e 8 F 3 now
the magic sauce can I call an API from
another mini from another micro service
and have that trusted inside of Dockers
local network yes I can I created that
API certificate there and it is trusted
as well now it's not the same
certificate this is F 4 3 7 9 2 but that
certificate is trusted by the same root
certificate I've trusted this root
certificate of my local machine I've
trusted it in each of my containers and
so I can make trusted connections to all
of the places that I need to this is
really cool I can use HTTPS inside of
docker and still start to experience the
way my website should behave in
production in production yes use let's
encrypt because we can't use it Inlet
because we can't use let's encrypt in
development let's instead use this
mechanism for being able to sign
interesting things we walk through each
of these demos where we did interesting
things to try and build up the
development certificate we did a whole
kind of interesting thing here on step 6
and ultimately abandoned it but mixed
cert is really cool at
doing interesting things to be able to
use development certificate straightaway
as you pull these details these slides
from Roberta org here's some other
reference material if you want to dig in
deeper and that's what I've got thank
you for coming what shins yes what if
the API was only available inside the
network it would still work just fine
because I have that trust chain between
them I can make those requests I just
happen to expose the API publicly just
so that I could poke out it too but if I
flipped over to Cooper Nettie's and made
it a cluster IP rather than a publicly
accessible API that would be just fine
as well thanks for coming